when teenaged nerd Peter Parker is
bitten by a radioactive spider he gains
a weird selection of arachnid powers and
spends the rest of his days balancing
vigilante crime fighting against leading
a normal life except it's never really
been that simple for our friendly
neighborhood spider-man
and his history has so many twists and
turns that it's not easy to keep track
of his tangled web a true original
in 1954 Halloween costume manufacturer
Ben Cooper Inc began selling a
spider-man outfit the kids sized duds
were little more than a yellow ensemble
covered with drawings of webs and the
word spider-man written across the
forehead giving the overall impression
of well a poorly dressed idiot who'd
recently escaped from a basement or
something
years later Marvel spider-man made his
debut in 1962 s amazing fantasy number
15 the final issue of a doomed anthology
series while Cooper's earlier Spiderman
may seem like a huge coincidence the
case is complicated by rumors that Jack
Kirby the original artist for spider-man
before Steve Ditko took over was working
for Ben Cooper at the time comics site
Newsarama explored the case and got a
terse reply from Ditko and silence from
Marvel which definitely sets our
spider-sense is tingling spider origins
Redux artist Jack Kirby had his hands in
the creation of just about every major
comic character you've ever heard of
while the first appearance of spider-man
was written by Stan Lee and drawn by
Steve Ditko
Lee originally had Kirby draw the first
five pages of Spidey's debut the pages
didn't hit the mark and were scrapped
for the final version Lee's original
plot and Kirby's costume designs were
changed and Kirby ultimately only drew
the cover of amazing fantasy number 15
unfortunately this didn't stop Kirby's
heirs from trying to claim payment for
Marvel's use of spider-man in 2009 even
Lee Kirby's everlasting partner in
mighty Marvel creativity denied the
Kirby family's claim according to
Deadline the suit was settled on
undisclosed terms in 2014 which is even
more suspicious than Norman Osborn's
crazy cornrows 20 Ingram Street over the
course of 1989 s amazing spider-man
numbers 300
Skeen and 317 readers were shown two
halves of a change of address form
filled out by Peter Parker and only
curious readers who assembled them saw
that the Parkers were now living at 20
Ingram Street in Forest Hills New York
whether or not this was an easter egg
planted by writer David McCauley knee or
artist Todd McFarlane is unknown but as
of 1974 there really was a family named
Parker at that address who soon began
receiving mail addressed to the
fictional Peter when the New York Times
explained the story in 2002 they also
discovered that 19 Ingram Street was
home to a family named Osborn just one
letter off from spider-man's
arch-nemesis Norman Osborn back in black
when he's not wearing his red and blue
duds
spider-man is known for wearing a
stealthy and slimming black which he
found in an alien vending machine during
1984 his Secret Wars miniseries and
decided to slap on his body what readers
might not know is that the black costume
wasn't an original idea from marble but
one sent in by a fan for a contest in
1982 while Randy Schuler's costume idea
apparently involved underarm webbing
which didn't make it into the sketch and
a red logo the similarities to the
official black suit remain Schuler was
paid for his idea two hundred and twenty
dollars which would be about five
hundred and fifty dollars today
Schuller's other ideas would later be
incorporated into additional Spidey
costume ideas unstable molecules and
thought control were both used by
Spidey's Future Foundation and iron
spider costumes respectively but Schuler
was never given any actual credit
according to his own post on Comic Book
Resources Center of the web comics fans
might not think about it much but
spider-man is the absolute center of the
Marvel multiverse
even though heroes like Captain America
and Iron Man get top billing there are
more versions of spider-man across the
multiverse than any other hero and
anytime we visit another reality
spider-man is so iconic and consistent
that he's always there and generally
used as a compass to differentiate the
different planes of existence while the
main Marvel continuity earth-616 has its
own fair share of the Spidey's there are
literally hundreds of alternates
including spider-ham of Earth 83 one one
the flaming skull headed ghost spider of
Earth one one six three eight and a
whole lot of dead spider-man
since Peter seems to get caught in the
old bug zapper of life pretty often
the cruelest revenge spider-man has
probably had the roughest life of any
superhero
he doesn't have Batman's wealth and he
doesn't have Superman's strength but he
accomplishes pretty much the same heroic
stuff but the very worst thing that ever
happened to spider-man was being cheated
on by his girlfriend when Stacy with his
arch-nemesis Norman Osborn aka the Green
Goblin
while this was never spoken of during
Gwen's life the 1999 storyline sins past
revealed the ultimate betrayal Gwen had
kept her terrible goblin baby secret and
because of their unique DNA they aged
rapidly and came after Peter Parker
because that's what goblins do everyone
Peter Parker and comic readers included
hated the whole thing
spider magic everyone knows that
spider-man's powers are purely
scientific in nature because being bit
by a radioactive animal automatically
transfers its powers to you that's just
basic biology except in 2001 the arrival
of a character named Ezekiel revealed
that Spidey superhuman abilities were
actually kind of magic and that faithful
radioactive spider bit Peter Parker on
purpose because of cosmic mystical
machinations it's a bit like the
midi-chlorians of the Marvel Universe
but it also kinda explains why most of
Spidey's bad guys are animal themed deal
with the devil the apex of weird
spider-man storylines is Peter Parker's
deal with the devil Mephisto in exchange
for the survival of his dear decrepit
nearly deceased anyway Aunt May Spidey
would give up his marriage and future
kids with Mary Jane forcing him straight
back into the friend zone
Spidey's reason for taking this deal
Peters Aunt May was hovering between
life and death because she'd been put in
danger after he revealed his secret
identity during civil war and he'd come
to the sensible conclusion that taking
off his mask in front of the world had
been a big mistake in return for Peter
sacrificing his life with Mary Jane
Mephisto made the world forget he was
spider-man thus protecting his loved
ones from the line of supervillain fire
crossover madness Spidey is a guy who
gets around in some pretty weird places
in 1978 Peter and Mary Jane attend a
taping of Saturday Night Live and a
mix-up between villains silver samurai
and John Belushi's
my character causes an issue long ruckus
featuring the entire 1978 SNL cast in
1993 Marvel had the rights to publish a
comic series based on Ren & Stimpy
so spider-man ended up battling powdered
toast men in those pages and getting one
punch through a wall by the bread headed
hero and in 2009 Spiderman rescues none
other than Barack Obama from the
chameleon who decides to impersonate the
president-elect moments before the
inauguration and that's truly only the
tip of the weird bird so many spiders at
one point in Marvel's history spider-man
was so popular that he starred in four
books at once making it nearly
impossible to keep track of his
adventures or even take a nap all of it
came to a head when Norman Osborn framed
spider-man for murder
forcing Parker to drop his heroic
persona and take on a different heroic
mantle or four as Hornet and prodigy
Peter continued his heroics and as dusk
and ricochet he was able to infiltrate
New York's criminal underworld to find
the real murderer Spidey was able to
drop his alternate identities but they
were later taken up by a group called
the slingers who were quickly beaten by
the new warriors in a game of basketball
and pretty much never seen again Mary
Jane is not my lover
at some point during the 1990s pop star
Michael Jackson made moves to try and
purchase Marvel Comics only because he
wanted to play a heroic character when
it came time to make some Marvel movies
it was revealed in 2011 that Jackson
petitioned x-men's producers for the
role of Professor X for reasons that are
now a complete mystery to all humanity
but Stan Lee's recollection was
different in their personal
conversations Jackson revealed to lead
that he really wanted to play spider-man
though Tobey Maguire eventually got the
role probably saving the Marvel movie
universe as we know it trailer trashed
speaking of the original 2002 spider-man
the film's original theatrical trailer
had to be completely pulled and scrapped
after the events of 9/11 due to the fact
that the entire thing hinged upon a
helicopter being caught on a web between
the twin towers since the terrorist
attacks happened after much of filming
was completed but before the film's
theatrical release the towers were cut
from a handful of scenes the replacement
trailer featured spider-man
perching on an American flag instead
spandex sadness spider-man's many
portrays have all had very different
reactions to the tights Civil War
spider-man Tom Holland had costumes that
were designed for his stunt double so
when he put them on they were a bit too
baggy bumming out Holland during his
first time in the suit
according to comic book movie Tobey
Maguire was pretty uncomfortable until
the costume designers put in a bathroom
portal and despite bathroom breaks being
a known problem for spider actors the
costume department again forgot to
include a vital flap for Andrew Garfield
who only had the Edition put in during
his second outing as the character still
Garfield admitted during a radio
interview that he was so taken by the
fact that he got to play the iconic hero
that he cried when he first put on the
suits and we thought Toby was the Spidey
who cried turn off the dark
spider-man's films aren't the only times
he's been made into a live-action hero
in 2010 director Julie Taymor brought
Spidey to Broadway in a place so fraught
with problems that it quickly became an
unintentional comedy of errors
even with music by the members of u2 by
opening day the production had already
cost sixty five million dollars and not
even Disney who had recently purchased
Marvel had any interest in helping out a
disturbing number of actors and extras
were injured during production due to
the show's complex stunts and at one
point Green Goblin became stuck on a
wire over the audience hanging there for
a few minutes before the show could
begin again not even the Clone Saga was
this embarrassing spiders sentai
Broadway wasn't the only place to suffer
from a misguided live-action Spider Man
in 1978 Japanese production company
to--we took note of Spidey's tight
costume and likened him to their own
skin tight tokusatsu heroes like Kamen
Rider Japan Spiderman was given an
Origin not unlike DC's Green Lantern
when he's given a fancy device and
powers by an alien from the planet
spider who he finds in a crashed UFO
called Marvel ur in true Japan form
Spidey also gets a transforming robot
which he uses to fight against professor
monster the show ran for 41 episodes all
with Marvel's approval and with amazing
episode titles like becoming splendid -
the murderous machine of transformation
the onion silver mask and the boys
detective group spider-man amasian in
1992 Marvel and Sivan had a huge hit
with their x-men animated series so
Marvel decided to build on the success
by debuting spider-man in 1994 while
Spidey series was also an action figure
spawning phenomenon it was subject to
completely absurd censorship while it's
reasonable to request that a kid's
cartoon omit animated blood it made less
sense to forbid even the mention of
blood even in an episode where Morbius
the living vampire appears and can no
longer be called a vampire other rules
included no breaking glass no punching
except in limited circumstances and no
use of the word sinister this last one
is especially odd a Spidey's main
villain collective is known as the
sinister six and mr. sinister was over
on x-men being evil on a regular sorry
kids basic English vocabulary is too
rough for your little pudding brains and
bloodless bodies say no to bugs because
Spidey is pretty much an everyday
average guy he's been used countless
times as a tool for educational purposes
from direct to VHS shorts about child
abuse to full comic arcs about the
dangers of drugs when the US government
approached Stanley to write an anti-drug
story in 1971 he was all for it as long
as it was a good story strangely enough
this was during a time when the comics
code Authority also expressly forbade
any mention of drugs whatsoever after
the story was shot down by the comics
code Lee made the difficult decision to
publish it anyway it was so well
received that the CCA changed its own
code opening up comics to a much wider
range of educational stories oh baby
Spidey's strangest foray into
educational materials was definitely the
pull of The Prodigy a 1976 story written
by Anne Robinson for Planned Parenthood
in an amazingly surreal plot the alien
villain called prodigy no relation to
spider-man's previously mentioned alter
alter ego uses the powers of alien
persuasion to try to convince teenagers
to make babies so that he'll have tons
of minions to do his bidding part of the
prodigies propaganda was to straight-up
say that diseases weren't possible and
getting down in the backseat of a Chevy
didn't really cause pregnancies of
course Spidey laments how
toughies life is even without a rug red
and defeats the prodigy before it's too
late
if anyone was poised to lecture kids
about celibacy it was definitely nerdy
Peter Parker thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
what Spidey fact surprised you the most